[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is segment where viewers
try to find mistakes on our show so far
many challengers no winners we've met
them over a hundred people I believe
challenged us thinking they found a
mistake but not one person has actually
caught us making a mistake it always
turns out that we are right and they are
wrong well tonight and we're fair
tonight as fair is something more than
human candy I don't know I don't know
either
tonight a fan named Todd thinks he's
caught a mistake he says it happened
during a comedy sketch we did last week
about Jesus head Conan it's Todd from
Abilene Texas listen earlier this week
you showed the driver's license of Jesus
Christ
everywhere I go with my new ID I got
free drinks the problem is the hair
color abbreviation on that driver's
license is BL in which everybody knows
is the abbreviation for blonde now the
guy in the picture isn't blonde and we
all know Jesus Christ himself wasn't a
blonde so looks like a gotcha just admit
it
first of all Todd congratulations it's
cool to see that you were the proud
owner of the bed that Abraham Lincoln
died in that's what that's what's known
as Amish sexy but I'm sorry to be the
one to tell you Todd but you are
completely absolutely wrong
Jesus was blond for a short time back in
the year 1880 you think I'm wrong
check out this clip from a movie yes
they had movies back then the guy could
turn water to wine he couldn't make a
movie sure of course
all right thanks pal you got my back
check out this very rare clip from a
movie Jesus made that very year
[Music]
each bubble
[Music]
[Music]
standing ovations anyway shut up yeah I
love watching Jesus water-ski yeah it's
kinda like surfing sure yeah so the
challenge still stands if you think
you've spotted an error on our show
reported a team koco.com / haha I found
an error we will sort it out very fairly
right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chutney
out of the maestro